foreign
Jade in other news eggs are all the rage
among the youth my goodness today's
America and now there's like memes we're
making fun of it but there's a hilarious
article that uh we got sent what is it
unbelievable so the Nationwide egg
shortage an ensuing record price spikes
has led Americans to seek alternative
means to fulfill their appetite and
their baking needs you're never going to
guess what this is you can actually do
George a rent a chicken coop
yes your face is exactly right they will
bring me an actual Chicken Coop like the
wire fence and everything in my house so
that I can have eggs yes everything that
comes with it I mean they will come they
will deliver it they'll set it up uh
they'll help you set up these chicken
coops they come with a you know you can
decide how many chickens you want so for
instance for this one let's see you can
get two rented chickens so you get two
laying hens you get eight to 14 eggs per
week a standard Chicken Coop a food dish
a water dish and 100 pounds of chicken
feed plus your quick guide for taking
care of your rented chickens oh my
goodness and this is oh my gosh 485
dollars for six months over the six
months you pay 485 dollars this is that
comes out to about 80 bucks a month
I don't think that math is math in
George that math ain't math and right so
here's the deal if they're saying you're
gonna get eight to fourteen eggs per
week out of this let's call it a dozen
for easy numbers right yeah you're
getting a dozen eggs per week for 80
bucks a month that's 20 for a dozen of
eggs yeah no that I told you it ain't
nothing this is fun as like a I guess if
you you've got kids and they want to
know what it's like to be you know sure
and get closer to the food you're eating
that's a beautiful thing yeah but as
like an a hack for inflation this is the
worst hack I've ever heard of do you
kind of know what this reminds me of it
reminds me of when people are driving
their car right they've got their car
they're driving along and the car breaks
down and they're like I take it I gotta
get it repaired and they don't want to
pay the the bill to get it repaired so
they just get a new car oh yes that's
kind of like this I feel like it's oh my
gosh chicken prices you know I don't
want to pay the two to three dollars
more let me just go buy a whole chicken
and a whole food makes sense it doesn't
make sense they also have like an elite
package which is 13.85. the oatmeal 1
385 you get a fancier Chicken Coop and
you get 16 to 24 eggs a week
I don't even know I just looked at my
local like there's a you know there's a
little frou-frou grocery store nearby
called Sprouts yes here in Franklin
Tennessee and I just checked on their on
their page how much eggs are going for
it was 339 for a dozen of eggs it's
really not that serious George and I
even looked at like okay what are the
really bougie expensive you know the
chickens had a great life they saw the
sunshine they took them to Disney World
they laughed they cried even those eggs
were 8.99
you know what I think it it depends on
where you go because I know in some
states it's like super you know who
always comes at us as Canadians they're
always like well in Canada eggs are 19
for and I'm like listen I can't speak to
Canada y'all are y'all are doing things
differently out there you got poutine
your prices are out of whack not poutine
George I'm not coming after poutine I'm
just saying they do things differently
well here's what here's what I want to
get to I feel like in the economy things
happen and we just go to extremes like
remember in like 2008 gas prices were
crazy and everybody started buying smart
cars oh yeah like those ridiculous teeny
tiny cars and it's like this is the
solution to our problems a terrible idea
are people just like freak out and start
buying a bunch of gold and I'm like now
the eggs are expensive let's just we're
buying chicken wire we're buying whole
whole chickens whole coops this is a
symptom of something deeper if you're
really frantic right if you're really
freaking out about this if this if this
egg shortage is in the price increase is
if it's breaking your bank there's
something further beneath the surface
you're complaining about egg prices
going up you know 50 60 okay that
amounts to three bucks for a dozen of
eggs yeah that's probably 20 bucks Max a
month for y'all but then you're okay
sending a lender 500 bucks for that car
payment yeah and you're okay sending
Sallie Mae 400 bucks over here for your
student loan payment there's a it's
a real problem
it's your debt it's not the eggs folks I
never thought I'd have to say that
sentence out loud yeah if you want to
overcome this it's your debt we will
survive the bird flu egg shortage of
2023 and you can become debt free and
create margin in your budget and then
you're not really all that concerned
about egg prices you just adjust the
budget and move on with your life
sorry we had to explain that to you guys
oh George there we go there's my dad
joke for the day this is the Ramsay show